hello everyone
and welcome to another episode of
connecting the dots today on the show
we're bringing in
one of my favorite people uh kirk kemple
kurt thank you so much for joining us
today
yeah it is an honor and a pleasure
anytime i get a chance to talk to you is
a good day
so thanks for having me yeah i'm super
excited so
um you know you and i have a little bit
of background we used to work together
oh jeez oops did that thing where i
forgot to mute in the other channel
um story of my life geez
so yeah so here we are we got uh we we
you and i used to work together
um you've you've worked at uh major
league soccer you're currently working
at apollo
um i am i'm just super excited because
you have one of the more interesting
stories that i've heard
uh in in terms of breaking into tech and
and all of that but maybe we can start
with just a little bit of background um
so if you want to tell everybody
kind of what you're doing now what where
you are in your career right now
yeah so right now yeah and i just i like
to say yeah it's what the folks in the
biz call it non-traditional
background but
uh yeah yeah uh yeah absolutely but
right now currently i am a developer
relations manager at
apollo graphql uh so for folks who
aren't familiar apollo graphql has a lot
of like
open source tooling and a platform uh
that helps folks be successful with
graphql surprise prize um yeah so that's
kind of where i'm at now it's a very dev
advocacy
developer relations type focus role
which i've slowly transitioned to over
the last couple years
um before that just uh you know doing a
lot of uh development work and
things of that nature but yeah that's
where i'm at right now yeah for sure
and so you know and you've you've grown
from a position to you know you you
broke into tech a while back
how long have you been in the industry
now oh so i got my first like
professional
you know job um uh 2013. so
about coming up on like eight years in
january it'll be about eight years yeah
yeah so
um so you know over the course of that
eight years you've been able to go from
your your first job your entry-level job
to where you're now
a manager at a company that people have
know the name of
um you're you're in a position to kind
of hire you're growing a team
that's that's pretty exciting stuff um
and i think
maybe a little unexpected given
uh your background right so so maybe i
think what would be really fun to talk
about to start
is where did you come from like what
happened before you broke into tech
uh a whole laundry list of things
happened before i broke into tech
uh you know it's always tough to like
figure out where to
start um but i'll say this i
i learned how to code i started learning
how to code uh when i was incarcerated i
was actually serving time doing
hard time uh it actually was really hard
but uh
yeah so um before that i worked a lot of
odd
and end jobs i dropped out of high
school when i was probably about 16
years old i think my memory is honestly
very fuzzy of anything
before uh like my time in incarceration
and the reason for that is
drug addiction so i suffered
from drug addiction i was real deep in
the throes of it from about the time of
14 years old
until about 22 years old when i was
incarcerated
and yeah so i worked odd in
jobs like line cook i worked for a
general contractor for a long time did a
lot of construction
uh stuff like that uh and then yeah yeah
that's pretty much the gist of it before
that yeah then i did about seven years
uh locked up and that's where i was
actually introduced to programming
yeah so um i'd actually love to hear
about that like
how did you get introduced to
programming while you were locked up
uh so one of the things that happened is
like you know i spent about a year in
jail
um and i had a lot of time for the fog
in my brain to kind of clear
uh and so when i when i was before the
judge and i got
sentenced in there like five to seven
years uh
you know time in prison that was like a
like getting hit with a hammer right in
your chest
and uh you know i i don't really
remember what the trip like
was getting back to the jail and all
that i just remember
that night just making a promise to
myself i wasn't going to waste a minute
of time i was going to take any programs
that they made available to me i was
going to do whatever i could
to make sure that uh when i got out i
would only be as far
back um you know as set back as possible
like yes
i'm out of here but maybe i can learn
some useful skills and some things to
apply when i get out
um so i just took a blanket uh
uh offering of courses you know i got
certified in hvac
carpentry electrical work plumbing
landscape
design uh dog training um
what else like all kinds of things
literally anything that was offered a
cooking program
yeah and then uh so what happened was i
had like no skill with computer so i
actually started out taking like a
course on how to use like microsoft
office and i took a typing course and
and these other type of things and then
they offered something on networking so
i started to like get into i.t
and how computers actually work and how
to build them and stuff so it was very
cool
and then uh just there was this uh one
course intro to like
either web design or web development i
can't remember it was like in all caps
on the certificate like
just some like weird course and it was
yeah it was
html css and just a splash of javascript
and uh that was i was hooked as soon as
i
i got my first hello world h1 and i hit
refresh in the browser
and i saw that update like neurons just
started firing i'm like i know how the
internet works
like uh like i said in the matrix like i
know kung fu
you know it's like it was pretty cool
nah that's great um well so that
actually is really fascinating because i
um i knew you had learned to code when
you were inside but
i didn't realize that you had also
picked up all those other skills
so when you so when you got out
did you immediately go into web dev or
kind of what was the path
between between then and your first job
yeah it was a very very hard path it was
probably the hardest three years
of my life honestly even counting
prison time counting uh my time
in the throes of drug addiction uh and
the reason why is because i
had accumulated a lot of valuable skills
but uh
when you are a felon nobody really wants
to hire you
you have a lot of other people who have
skills as well so
whenever i have to check that little you
know are you a felon box or have you
been convicted of a felony within the
last seven years
never get the call back never so yeah
i'm certified hvac
you know i i you know i'm trying to get
jobs in welding shops and trying to get
jobs
i t anything like blanketing across i
can't even work at target or mcdonald's
like
you know and and i think people uh just
kind of
don't realize like recidivism is so
high because folks don't have stability
when they get out they get out they want
to do better nobody wants to go back to
prison it's not like i was in there with
a bunch of folks who are like [ __ ]
oh sorry shoot as soon as i get out of
here yeah oh you know i'm gonna go
commit a crime and come right back
because this place is fantastic
you know that's just like not it you
know uh and it got close i almost ended
up
uh uh going back to dealing drugs
because i had no money i had no things
but instead
i said you know what like screw these
companies um they're not gonna give me a
chance so i stopped checking the box
and what i would do uh is i would work
at a job for about three or four weeks
until they would do a background check
and they'd be like you're one of our
best workers but like we have to let you
go because you you know you didn't
check the box and i'm like well when i
check it you don't call me back
don't worry i've already applied to like
seven other places so i'll go work there
for a few weeks
and that whole time i was just self uh
self-guided learning right i was
you know building things uh in
in my spare time when i could uh
watching things on youtube
uh you know just doing a whole bunch of
stuff
so yeah uh it was pretty rough uh but
eventually i landed a job
at a company called golden mobile and uh
yeah yeah and that was like my first
breakthrough
yeah was them giving me a chance it was
cool
but it was a really weird situation too
because what happened was they hired me
and i worked there for a couple weeks i
was doing a fantastic job and like oh we
totally forgot to have you fill out the
background check
here it comes right like here it is
again every time it's always like the
background check
and uh yeah so you know i i
i was like okay so i'm left with this
choice like you know what do i do here
right so
uh i was working on this product i just
like finished it like i was just like i
did i just worked on it like all night
i finished it and i brought it to my
manager in the morning
and i was like hey i completed the
project this is the type of work that
you can expect from me should you choose
to let me stay on
my background check you it's going to
see that you're going to see i have a
record
uh i was like but because of that like i
have a lot to prove
you know and i'm really willing to work
extra and it sucks that you you get kind
of put into that situation
and uh yeah so you know it's just like
i had no choice but to overwork myself
uh and do that and then it was just
weird like they let me stay on but for
six months i just felt like everybody
was just like looking at me differently
um it felt like i had gotten over on
them i don't know and
i think a lot of that was internal i was
internalizing a lot of things
stigma about people with records um but
it was hard but it was my break it was
the thing that got me in there it got me
six months of experience
uh and had a little something on my
resume for you know to to move forward
with but yeah it was
took about three years from release to
first job
so so one of the things that i love to
talk about on the show and that that i
think
is um is just so important to focus on
is
this idea that you know getting into
tech
is hard right and we're going to talk a
little bit more about like how everybody
watching can
can break into tech a little bit later
in the show but for now i kind of want
to focus on this idea that
like you you had to break and detect not
with your technical skills
but with a whole range of other skills
you know that you had to
there was so much perseverance and there
was a little bit of
kind of ingenuity or craftiness in in
getting
just through the interview process
because you had to check that box
um where do you feel like you picked up
those skills like what what skills did
you use that aren't tech skills that
helped you land this first job
yeah you you pick up skills from
everywhere and i'm so glad that you
bring that up because
you know a lot of folks feel like if
like
we focus so much on technical ability
that we forget that that's actually a
very small part of the day-to-day job
like yes you might write a decent amount
of code but there's a whole
lot of other responsibilities and things
that you need to be pretty good at
in order to succeed right and so
a lot of the things that really helped
me was like working construction
and as a line cook understanding how to
prioritize
and organize the workload and make sure
that you're doing things in the correct
order those are invaluable skills
taking a large uh job and breaking that
down into smaller pieces that
happens every day in the construction
world every day you know it goes from
like
yeah every day if you're framing a house
you don't say i'm gonna frame a house
it's like first we gotta lay the yeah
yeah first we gotta lay down the
foundation
right we got to set everything up to get
the flooring on then we're going to
stand up some walls right and then we're
going to
we're going to uh you know we're going
to start working on the second floor and
it's like you work up and then it's like
eventually before you know you got a
roof
but you don't start like we build the
house right you break it down into its
tiny itty-bitty pieces and also
i learned a lot of valuable skills about
working with other teams other
people so as a framer we have to work
with the plumbers we have to work with
the electricians
understand their needs making sure that
our part of the job is done in time so
that
they can come behind and do their part
of the job so invaluable skills
you learn the same things in the kitchen
uh if if you want to see
orchestration like at its finest watch
line cooks because when you have like an
order
of you know like a 10 people order come
in and everything needs to finish
at about the same time and they have
different you know different needs as
far as like where it's being cooked
for how long it needs to be cooked three
items on the menu might be the same
thing but needed to be done
at like different uh temperatures you
know we look at like steaks or burgers
right
and it's like you you have to
orchestrate all this not just within
your station but with the
rest of the team and if you're not
communicating you're never going to get
that done
uh it's never going to be right if
you're going in there and you're like
well i'm just going to worry about just
my little piece and forget the rest like
everything's going to fall apart you
know you're not going to you're not
going gonna succeed in that role
uh so i think things like that are
extremely transferable
yeah and then that kind of br yeah yeah
it brings me to my next point which is
empathy and understanding uh and this
was something that i really
started to uh uh internalize
and and realize in my time incarcerated
uh just understanding like that your
perspective of the world
is not the center of everything it's not
the default that lots of other people
have lived
experiences uh that are very different
from yours
and thinking about others whenever
you're doing something so that was a
huge thing to learn
and then lastly uh understanding
uh folks like investments in things and
then just kind of like
being able to to kind of understand how
people are feeling like in a in a given
situation like
in prison you have to know whatever what
everyone around you is thinking
24 7. you never get to turn that off
right like i need to know if the person
next to me has malicious intent
i need to know if the person on the
other side of me might like
be suicidal like there's a lot of like
interesting uh
dynamics there that in order to just
walk through
you have to literally know how everyone
around you is feeling you have to start
learning body language how to pick up on
micro
cues and micro aggressions understand uh
when is a appropriate time to approach
folks and when not to and i think like
of all the skills that i've learned that
has been the most valuable
it helped me the most in my career and
like what i mean by that like a
like actual situation that i can compare
in the tech world is
let's say uh it's coming up for review
time and
i think somebody on my team should be
getting a raise right like i'm ready to
make this case but i kind of want to
like
start talking to my manager about this
now if i walk up to my manager and i can
see that their heads down
working on something or maybe even
slightly frustrated or something like
that like
it's probably not the best time to be
asking these type of questions i
one i need to be able to get their full
attention and
two uh i want to catch them uh when
they're probably in a much happier state
right like
i don't want to to you know you want to
be able to like
have have as good an opportunity as
possible
and so sometimes that's reading body
language understanding what people's
you know uh responsibilities are what
their investments are like what you know
what are they trying to get out of this
and and how can you
help show them that by doing this
they're going to achieve their goals as
well
so just understanding people is like
paramount
you know the more that you can work on
that the the better you'll be
yeah and and you know when you when you
said that i just it kind of
connected a couple dots in my head where
i was thinking about like you know that
that's actually one of the most
valuable skills i've seen when you get
to any team of
a bigger group than you can have a
single meeting with right so
you know once you cross about 12
suddenly you're not
having conversations where everyone is
on the same page
now you're having to have conversations
where everybody's got their own sliver
of the larger picture
and what i think is really interesting
about that is that where empathy plays
into that and where being able to read a
situation or understand someone's
motivations
like if i want you know if i if i'm a
engineer and i want to convince the
product team that we should build
something a certain way i shouldn't go
make a case for
why it's a great technical solution
that's not their
interest that's not their motivation
instead i should be
as you said think about what they want
think about what their
concerns are what's stressing them out
and if i can frame
my technical solution in a way that
solves their problems
i'm so much more likely to get that
decision adopted
um 100 100 know the stakeholders
and know what their investments are if
you're armed with that information
it makes it so much easier to to bring
up points
and to uh raise uh the right questions
or the right
statements or solutions because you know
what everybody is involved in this for
and why
they care about it empathy right it
always comes back to like communication
empathy you know those are the to me the
most valuable skills that you can
possess across any job honestly
absolutely especially in tech as well
yeah if you're going to work with people
being able to read people is going to be
like number one no matter what the the
underlying job is
um yeah and it's yeah but we have to be
careful because like there are a lot of
folks who that doesn't come as naturally
to
uh so um you know luckily that is
something that i've been able to develop
i also did read
a lot of books on on these exact topics
and stuff as well
uh yeah same yeah so it is a a learnable
skill
you know it's not just either you have
it or you don't um uh but yeah there's a
lot of folks who
um you know might not be as like
emotionally attuned
and so you know we have to you know uh
preface that yeah
it could definitely be a lot harder for
folks to achieve this but it's
definitely a valuable skill if you can
get yourself there
so you just said something that i'd love
to dig into a little bit and i i know
that we've got questions coming from the
chat uh quincy's doing a great job of
cueing those up and we will get to those
but uh
i want to talk a little bit about this
um you said
it's a learnable skill and yeah one of
the things that
i find most fascinating is the way that
individual people go about learning so
when you're up against learning
something that doesn't come naturally to
you
so for me learning how to have those
conversations with people how to be
empathetic that was not natural to me it
was something i had to put a lot of work
into
um when you come up against something
like that what is your preferred way to
learn
a new skill well that's really good and
it's
uh actually kind of situational
but i would say most things uh i am more
of what's called like a kinetic learner
i learn best by doing
um and so i'll take input from multiple
different avenues whether that be like
reading
listening to things watching other
things but until i start
to do it myself it's very hard to put
into place
um so depending on like what the skill
is it can be hard to get yourself into
these
uh situations so for me when it was uh
uh
you know i was kind of like forced into
learning this because i was incarcerated
so i was actually thrown into these
situations
uh every single day uh which made it
basically impossible to not be
practicing it but you still have to be
very careful so what i would just start
doing is applying this to my
everyday life and what i mean by that is
like
having empathy is something that isn't
just necessary
in in like business communication it's
very um
uh also very important inside your
personal relationships
right so i would start applying these
practices like
okay am i listening more than i am
speaking right like
i start taking the parts out of these
books like the things they want me to
try
uh and i would essentially just like
break that down and just focus
on little bits of it and try to apply
that until it becomes muscle memory and
move on to the next step
so in the first case do i listen more
than i talk when i'm interacting with
folks that's something
that i'd like to focus on once that
started to become natural the second
thing would be
okay am i understanding their investment
in something like if they're
upset about something like do i really
know why like yes my friend is upset but
why are they upset right and it's like
trying to understand
that then i would start moving on to
things like body language
here's a really fun fact um when you
enter into
a room and you see somebody that you
know
um and this doesn't mean like whether
they like you or dislike you but you can
generally tell whether or not they're
like
excited by your presence because in some
form or fashion they will fight
gravity that could be raising their
eyebrows the shoulders coming up
exactly a smile where they actually
doesn't go back but it goes out
a little they wave literally anything
where they fight gravity because gravity
is always working against us so if i'm
willing to work against gravity
that means i'm actually interested
enough invested enough to
show you that it's subconscious but like
99 of the time it's on point yeah
it doesn't mean whether someone is happy
to see you or not but if you're my
manager and i walk into the room and i
see those eyebrows go up it's probably a
great time to ask you a question about
something that i've been wanting to run
by you
sure right yeah whereas if i get the
straight face and i can tell you're
somewhere else and you're not
focused it's probably not the best time
uh
and so that's just like yeah yeah
there's like one you know
a little bit of it but yeah it's like
kind of like understanding that stuff
breaking things again breaking things
into smaller pieces attacking them one
at a time
until you build it up is what you would
consider to be a base skill that you now
possess
and moving on to the next thing
absolutely um
so i so i guess maybe like a good a good
thing to move into here is
a lot of the folks watching right now
have been asking a lot of questions
about how to get their first job and so
um i've got a few questions here the
first one is from mila
and mila's asking about um what
certificates
should should she get to get into the
world of software programming and coding
um do you do you think that certificates
i mean you so you mentioned that you got
certified in a handful of things when
you were inside
um what role have you seen certain
certificates play
uh in i mean you're hiring now right so
like what are you
what are you looking for in that yeah
yeah i'm hiring now i've been a hiring
manager before so
there's one thing that i want to uh
state here real quick too which is like
i have a privileged path into tech and
so
uh my path and what i've done you know
uh will work
um but for a lot of folks you know it's
just it's
a true statement it will be a lot harder
for other people
than uh myself to break into tech even
with a background
uh you know we have a big problem with
that in the tech industry
and uh so i just want to preface that
but yes there are still a lot of things
that you can do
that really do stand to help you stand a
better chance of like
breaking into tech and uh i think
certificates
can play a role i think it might be less
about certificates and more about
until you have work experience you need
something to put on a resume
people need something to take a first
glance at right and now this could be
certificates it could be a portfolio
that you've built you could take on
some freelance projects if you can do
that but ideally you want
something that you can put right at the
top of your resume
that's really going to help people get
an idea of your
current level of skill right and again
well this is very hard
i i what i would say on top of that is
that it's it's your current level of
skill and it's also the job that you
want like i what i've noticed is that um
people tend to get hired for the skills
that they put out there so
um a lot of times when someone has a
broad
variety of skills there's a then art of
like
elevating the ones that you want to get
hired for and potentially
not emphasizing so if you're currently
working in it or like systems networking
and you don't want to do that anymore
you want to do software you should
highlight the certificates around
like software engineering and and maybe
bury the it stuff because you don't want
to get hired as another
in another id role absolutely so
something yeah
i'm so glad that you brought that up so
i just want i'll finish this thought
real quick and then i want to
jump directly into that uh there's
studies that show when folks look at
your resume they go
top left just below that to the left and
then over to the right and then
everything else below that kind of falls
off right and
uh i've tested this against myself i do
the exact same thing those are the spots
that my eyes get drawn to first and
that's where people are going to look
so i always recommend a two column
layout with your most important
information your most important
experience whether that is a certificate
a
particular project that you're proud of
the one thing that you really want to
showcase
and then to the right like the next
important thing that you think is
ancillary to that that will help you get
that done
i have found this to be an invaluable uh
tool to help and then actually yeah to
speak to your point
not only will i bury things that are
irrelevant to the role that i'm
currently working at or working towards
but i will also put together
multiple versions of my resume this is
something that i do
very often uh maybe i'm willing to take
a
a role in dev advocacy and a
engineering role or particularly a
management role
you cannot create one resume that you'll
be able to submit for all those jobs
that are going to highlight the right
things because right
another piece of advice is keep your
resume to one page people
rarely go to page two and anything
that's on there
might as well as not be on there uh and
because you only have that one page
like you said it's so important to
highlight those things for the job that
you want
so i'll have different cover letters and
resumes for each type of role that i'm
going to
know that i'll apply for it's a little
bit of extra work but i find that it
really lets me focus in on the things
that are going to show off what makes me
good for that job
yeah where this starts to differ is
because if you're just breaking in
uh to tech you're not going to have a
huge background of work to pull from
but you have an entire life of
experience to pull from
yeah and just how we were talking about
the transferable skills
you know working at mcdonald's you learn
a lot of very valuable skills and it's
if you you know when you're putting that
on your resume listing out the things
like
coordinating uh you know between uh
multiple
uh teammates to to deliver uh you know
uh meals you know uh on time right and
properly organizing and prioritizing you
know uh balancing workloads between
you know what i'm doing here or doing
there maybe you took on some management
responsibilities in these roles like
that's all
very valuable so don't discount your
your life experience it's
it's absolutely i look at that yeah my
my first job
uh i got because i had you know graphic
design work and
and print printing press pre-production
work and all of that
helped me build enough like adjacent
experience
to be able to convince someone to give
me a shot on the
on the real job right um yeah i think
that that's uh that's a really really
good point like
and the other thing too is you know a
certificate you can choose which
certificates to get you don't have to
um you don't have to do that with
an employer's permission you don't have
to get hired you can take that
certificate
similarly with projects so there's a
question from humza
about how good is the approach of
learning a skill by doing projects right
away
um and so i'm gonna i'm gonna pass this
to you but what i'll say up front is
if you are trying to get a job doing
animation or if you were trying to get a
job
as a full stack engineer build projects
that do
that work because i know for me like if
if i see that all the work you do is in
the service of the job you're applying
for
i know that you're interested even if
it's your first career right
um and so yeah so what what uh what
would you recommend for someone like
certificates projects something else
should they freelance
where where should people go that's
that's a
fantastic question i think it is going
to boil down a little bit to preference
so
um i do i do love projects because that
allows you to
generally create something that like you
can mix in your passion so learning is
hard
and in order to stay motivated it's
really nice to be able to mix in like a
little bit
of things that you like and enjoy uh and
so when you learn by doing when you
build
projects like uh for me there's like a
couple things you know that i really
like i like longboarding
um you know i dabble in video games and
stuff like that
you know i have like some other
interested interests like around
collectibles and fun things and like
i can take any of those and turn those
into a project right or build
something around my interests and by
doing that
uh it's going to help me when i get
frustrated you know hopefully that
passion can be enough to kind of carry
you through
uh and see you through to the end it
also shows through a bit of your
personality which i think goes a long
way and and
people um i guess undervalue um
it's okay to shine a little bit and and
and have some individuality
uh i like when i see resumes they don't
have to be like you know this like big
graphic design project but
when it's a little bit different than
you know just a standard like word doc
with bullets listed out i love it
because i get to like you know just get
a peek at
um uh you know someone like putting in a
little bit of themselves into things and
i think whenever you put a little bit of
yourself into something you're gonna
invest a little bit more in it
and it's nice but i would also say it's
like deciding on how you learn
it you know some people like structure
right like if you like school and you
you learn well in a structured
environment certificates are probably a
fantastic way
to continue growing and to build up
something to put on the resume
if you kind of like to do your own thing
and just kind of build stuff and
discover things as you go go with
projects because you're going to be able
to do that
um freelancing can be quite a bit of
burden
because you also have to then understand
the freelancing market nothing
uh infuriates me more than folks who are
branching out they get into freelancing
and end up just with these like red flag
clients like
terrible clients you know and they you
know i have friends going through this
right now you know
the scope creep the project grows it
turns from a learning experience into
like a doom
project you know right yeah i hate to
see that so i'm always a bit weary of
freelancing but
taking on small projects could be a good
way and if you need
money it's also not a bad option as well
you get to add things to your portfolio
while you
build a little bit of of uh revenue so
well
and something that will happen whether
you wanted to or not when you take on
freelance work is you're going to learn
things about
management about planning about you know
being communicative how to like tell
people about setbacks in a way that
doesn't blow up the relationship
all those things those are very valuable
skills um
very valuable not a super fun way to
learn them
if you're doing it for the first time
with a with a freelance client but
uh you will build a whole different set
of skills along with that
absolutely absolutely but if i'm being
honest uh
you know to me i think that still one of
the best ways this day and age
to break into tech is to focus on
building
a community building a network
a lot of folks called i like to say
community network rings hollow to me
community rings
as something that is uh two-way right
like you're helping others as they're
helping you
and learning in public learning in
public is another very valuable way to
do a lot of those skills that you just
mentioned you're learning how to
communicate
clearly you're showcasing that you are
able to break problems down distill them
and share them
what you've learned with others
invaluable skills uh to have in
in programming or in general uh and so
you know honestly
uh while you're looking for jobs you
should always be thinking about
you know what does my community look
like how can i grow that
in a in a healthy way right and
you know yeah and you know because most
of the times the jobs that
you really are going to love uh and the
the opportunities
shine rarely come from uh not it's not
always the case there's always
exceptions but rarely does it come from
you dropping your
your application through a contact us
form you know
um a lot of times it comes fro from a
network right like people
they understand who you are in the
community they've seen the stuff you're
doing it lines up with what they're
trying to do and then boom
you know next thing you know you're
interviewing at this this company
so it's always something i i recommend
too so uh there's a couple questions
that are
really closely related to this
especially given right now
where everyone's on lockdown due to
coronavirus
building a community getting a first job
a lot of the advice that that we've seen
in previous years is that people getting
into their first role should not do it
remotely
um and i think that there are some
arguments there
you know there's good reasoning for that
like when you are new to something it's
really nice to be able to sit next to
somebody
to have that support network to be
surrounded by people doing the same work
but that's not an option right now so
for uh
let's see both uh daniel and hamza are
asking
what how should that be approach for
people who are you know we have to build
a community remotely we have to get our
first jobs remotely what strategies
would you recommend for folks to
um to succeed there yeah
that's wow what an amazing question
yeah so i think the first thing that you
want to check and it's it
stinks because you know when it's your
first time you're not really in like a
position of power if you're already
in a job and you're comfortable you can
be a lot more nitpicky with the
companies that you're going to interview
with or jobs that you'll take as the
first time it can be hard but
i want to say you want to look out for
like uh what folks will call like red
flags around like remote work and
condition or
is this a company with a track record of
already working with juniors or will you
be the first
junior developer to come on that's one
question
alone that if you get the answer to that
can be a strong indicator
now if you are the first junior but
they're a company who's already been
working remotely for a lot of time and
they've built up those practices you're
probably safe but
if it's a company who's just got gone
remote because of covid
and they don't have a track record of
onboarding juniors already
it's probably going to be pretty
difficult doesn't mean it won't work
it just means that's something that you
might want to consider
and i think uh this circles back to if
you get in a habit of learning in public
uh one thing that's gonna come along
with that is asking a lot of questions
you know as you learn in public you're
not just gonna share what you learned
but you're gonna start to ask your
community questions
to to learn better and if you find
yourself in a position
a remote first company because it's your
first
junior development job over communicate
and i
you really can't over communicate but a
lot of folks want to hold back for
lack of feeling you know like they
should know something or they should
uh uh not you know save questions and
ask them all at one time
i say don't make find find the people
in the company who always seem awesome
about answering your questions there's
going to be people in any company
no matter how good or bad it is that
like to help folks
find them and ask them just constantly
ask them questions you're not bothering
them
they love it that's what they're there
for they want to help you
uh you know so i would say definitely
communicate early and communicate often
and this goes like even further don't
write up this whole
pull request right and make a bunch of
changes push it and then ask for a
change
right as soon as you create the branch
push it up and open a pull request
each commit push that up and ask for
feedback
early and often that is like my number
one piece of advice for folks
and and remember you can set a pull
request on github in draft mode which
means this isn't ready yet i'm just i'm
working on it and that
lets people see what you're doing uh
which i i i love that advice personally
like
one of the things that i really enjoy
about people who i'm i'm working with in
a
like a lead capacity where i'm kind of
helping level them up is
when there's that constant seeking of
feedback if
if somebody sends me 1500 lines of code
and they're like can you give me some
feedback on this i'm like
i mean i can but it's not going to be
nearly as good as if you'd sent me 100
lines of code
um and so it's you know it's definitely
one of those things that
you can optimize your environment right
if you if you
think about how it would feel to be on
the other end of this like
would you rather somebody has a problem
doesn't tell you about it gets the
company in trouble and then
like comes to you later and says hey i
know that our team's on the hook for
this thing but i didn't do it because i
wasn't sure how
here's my problem i know it's due today
or would you rather somebody said
hey i need to work on this and i'm not
quite sure can you help me unstick this
so that i can get started right there's
there's that like
i would much rather get asked early so
that the team gets all their work done
on time
right absolutely yeah without a doubt
it's just the cognitive overhead uh it's
a two-way street like
if you build things up it becomes a
large investment and that yes and
it's very hard for people to have the
resources
or energy to respond to that large
investment whereas if it's coming
through bite size
and like a constant flow it's a lot
easier right like the feedback loop is
much smaller
much tighter it's i can answer one or
two questions
15 times throughout a day much easier
than i can take an
hour to two hours to like review like a
very large pr
if that makes sense that absolutely
makes sense yeah i mean
and that's like that's how i think a lot
of us function is
as you know senior devs managers we
we get ourselves in a position where we
try to be quickly doing little bits of
work to move the whole team forward if
we have to drop everything to focus on
one effort the rest of the team
bottlenecks up
um and so that's you know it's it's also
like
these are the skills like these are the
things when i see somebody learning the
skill when i see somebody getting
really good at sending pull requests at
you know
sending like small scopes of work
instead of sending me
everything all at once that's when i
start to think like this person's get
they're getting it they're going to go
somewhere like
let's get them on the fast track right
so it's also a great way to advance in
your career
absolutely uh yeah because yeah it just
showcases
that uh you're starting to understand
you know feedback loops what it means to
think about other people's time in
relation to the things that you have to
do
um and it also just shows yeah your
willingness to communicate and
it's just it's just such a valuable
skill you know absolutely i
can't state it enough but yeah and so
that that willingness to communicate i
also think
builds confidence it give it when you
ask a question and you get an
answer that's a that's a small
confirmation that says
i'm this is okay and when you do that a
lot exactly
it builds that confidence it gets that
ball rolling and actually i'm going to
ask a question to you
uh from elliot uh because i think it's
related elliott says i'm hitting a lot
of walls where i get to the final round
of an interview
then i keep getting told that i'm too
junior or need more experience
what would you advise for someone to do
in this position
yeah uh that's really tough so honestly
elliott i feel that that
is more on the company that it is on you
uh i feel a lot of times companies
position roles as junior
and then you look at the requirements
for the role and what they want
out of it and it's not quite there um
but yeah
it is it's difficult but if you want to
improve that there are a couple things
that you can do and so to me this comes
back to like
projects right um this is why i like
projects actually that's how i got the
job at major league soccer um
i had started to understand uh uh
that like i was pushing you know outside
of front end rolls a lot of stuff i had
done previously had been front end
i got very curious about like the uh api
gateway layer and like back end work and
kind of what that looked like so
i set up like a microservices
architecture i took some time i tried to
invest in docker and understand like how
you would architect
having multiple different apis all
talking to one
and then turns out that was like exactly
what major league soccer was looking for
right they wanted a full stack developer
who knew really how to work from the api
gateway down but understood
at least what was happening a little
step further so i think it's
uh it's also a matter of being able to
talk about things and so um i always
like to think about things as like
drip learning like you hear about
different learning styles like shallow
learning which is like you know know a
little bit about everything
or t learning know a little bit about
everything dive deep in one thing
i'm a big fan of drip learning like only
learn what you need to know
to do like the very next step and
sometimes you'll learn a little bit and
sometimes you'll get down further but
you have this shallow pool and some
things just to kind of drip
all over the place yeah and a way to
achieve that
a really good way to achieve that is to
focus on hows
or sorry on whys over house and what i
mean by that
is like when you hear about a new
framework instead of stopping everything
you do
spin up a new project and start building
something with it like savelle or
something
like that step back and say well what is
the problems felt is trying to solve why
was it created
you know what is the difference between
it and react and why would i pick it one
over the other
that information is way more valuable
because anybody's going to be able to
pick up spell and eventually learn how
to use it right not everybody
understands why you pick spell
or why you would want this or why you
pick a microservices architecture over a
monolith and what are the benefits of
those two things right
right and so i think i you know i spent
a lot of time there's something like
thoughtworks has something called a
technology radar
uh which is a really good like quarterly
newsletter where they cover
all of the technologies that are like
emerging
uh and what they were built for and the
problems that they solve and stuff like
that and
sometimes your lack of experience is
really just like they want to hear like
more uh you be able to speak more
capably
about given topics it doesn't
necessarily mean that you don't
know something enough right it's just
that
you know you don't know the things you
need to know
to know what you would need to learn god
that's a lot but that
that's essentially what it is well and
and you know i'll
i'll add to that by saying one of the
things that stands out to me when i'm
interviewing somebody early career is
whether or not they give a strong
impression
that like i don't expect juniors to know
much like we're we're hiring them in
their first role like you're you're
supposed to have like bare minimum we're
going to teach you everything else
so i'm not looking for them to know
everything i'm looking for them to give
me that distinct impression
that they know they don't know but
they're very sure they can find out
and and if i get that sense that that
someone
is really like the self-starter
they are they're confident in their
ability to learn they believe that
any knowledge is accessible to them if
they get the time and energy to work on
it
right those are the types of people that
really stand out to me and i think that
goes back to that confidence
right like if if you come off as
not confident in your skills you're
early in your career you don't have to
be confident in your skills but be
confident in yourself
be confident in your capability to
expand and grow
that i can smell that a mile away and
i'm always looking for people who do
that
absolutely i'm looking for that all the
time as well because honestly when
you're junior we don't have a lot to go
off you know there's not a lot of work
history for us to examine
uh so we're really left with behavioral
questions
right like do you understand uh how you
would do things differently given a
reset on certain situations and they
don't have to be related to code
right but it's like all we're left with
is like
do they understand uh ways
to learn quickly right not necessarily
understand and master something quickly
but how to get the information
quickly that's the difference um and
yeah and and
you know behaviorally like are they
comfortable with critiquing themselves
retroing the things that they've done
and able to understand how they would
change things to do
better next time and those are
invaluable if you
if you present me with those two things
in an interview it's like yeah i
absolutely want you on my team this is
somebody who's going to come in with a
fresh set of eyes
they're going to look at the things that
we've got going on you know they're
going to be
offering us already insightful
information from the start
i can trust that as they learn and grow
they're going to be reflective of that
and figure out what they can always be
doing to
improve and they're going to go out and
seek that information now i'm going to
dump it on to you like just keep
anything onto you that you want but it's
still very cool to see
uh people have the skill and ability to
do it to themselves because you know
what there
are some times when maybe you know you
can't get to that question
fast enough and they're eager to pick
something up and boom off they go with
it yeah
and that's growth right like when what i
love to see is when you get somebody who
comes in
and they start out they're junior
they're fresh they don't know anything
but as you dump that information on them
you never have to dump that same
information twice you start to see them
answer questions and the things that
you've taught them they're
they're quick to step up and and pick up
those issues
and that to me is those are the signs
that really show me that somebody's
gonna grow well
um and i you know i'd love to i'd love
to see that
uh so i absolutely i have another
question for you
that uh we're gonna loop it back a
little bit because you made a mention
about you know people who are looking
for their first careers
they don't have the luxury and the
privilege of being as choosy
as someone who's later in that program
and and they
might just have to take the job that's
available not the job they want
so uh so turth is asking if you interned
at a company that doesn't pay well but
you're getting exposure to
to frameworks and tools and and
practices um
should you should you be looking to quit
should you be looking to
do so like how do you how do you take
that
situation and turn it to your advantage
instead of getting stuck
yeah and again this is really tough
because it depends on
where you land right but absolutely one
thing that i really appreciate with
different companies is when
uh you have a little bit of time to
learn actually so here's something that
i do um i have like a 70 30 rule
i dedicate 70 of my time at a job
towards the actual job and the goal
at hand and i dedicate about 30
sometimes a little less in
in crunch time towards growing
and learning as a developer so even if
the time isn't technically allotted to
you but kudos to all you companies out
there that are giving folks the ability
and time to learn
uh we appreciate you uh but yeah if
you're not giving it you have to kind of
give it to yourself
uh so when you join a company and you're
starting in that role
never come in there at 110 because what
happens is that becomes your baseline
and as soon as you set a baseline of 110
that becomes expected of you and then
when it becomes crunch time now they
need 130
but you've got nothing left to give
right you're already at everything
so i really come in at about 70 80
productivity and i'm
always dedicating the rest of that time
to learning
and to growing and then leaves me a 20
bandwidth to push in crunch times when
we really need to get things
done it's going to help you prevent
burning out spectacularly
uh and it's going to allow you that time
that you need to always be growing and
doing your career now you might find
yourself in a situation where it's kind
of too late you've already been given
110
uh and you don't really feel like you're
growing and then this comes really down
to like a work-life
balance time uh management situation
where
it's like you have to figure out a way
to advance your skill set
without you know again burning yourself
out hurting yourself some things that
you could do or trying to switch teams
maybe the team that you're on you feel
like you've really learned it you're
kind of stagnating there are there other
teams in the company that you could join
who are doing some of the things that
you're interested in
maybe that's like moving from a front
end to a back end role or like you know
trying to branch out there uh getting
involved in
open source like or uh could be a good
way if you have the bandwidth to start
experimenting with things on a small
scale
uh meetups like now everything is
virtual
so meetups and and talks are a good way
to get exposure
to different topics that thoughtworks
technology radar will kind of keep you
abreast
of everything that's going on and then
just dabble but just be careful be very
very careful of burnout the first like
two years of my development career and
it really did
took its toll on me physically and
mentally i was burnt out
suffered deeply from depression i was
going like 18 hours
you know a day super unhealthy super
super unhealthy
i was just in a place i was in a digital
agency
after gold mobile i went to my first uh
digital agency role in new york city i
thought you know i'd made it
i'm in the city ma and uh so yeah
yeah uh i thought i'd made it but anyway
it turned out to just be like a
developer mill
um you know they they impossible
deadlines the technology stack
never changed so just after you know six
months it just
felt very like repetitive i felt
stagnated
uh and it was hard it was hard to do
that so i just like
you know i would spend a little bit of
time i had on my commute just trying to
understand
uh the housing wise and yeah so it's
just like
you know it's about optimizing and again
focus on house or wise over house
because
your next role you'll probably learn
those things like i i might not expect
you to know
docker but i would expect you to
understand what docker is
and why we would use docker right and
like i won't expect you to
you know know the particular frameworks
that we're using for an api but
i would expect you to just be able to
talk about apis in general and like you
know some some basic questions
and and uh problems that you might face
when building an api
so it's like really just like knowing um
why someone
picks a technology or would choose it is
in my opinion way
better than being uh very deep and
specific into one thing it also kind of
funnels you into
like uh you know a particular silo right
like
that's all you're known for right like
you know you become
d3 person or something like that maybe
you want to learn something else but
that door kind of gets closed off for
you like you were saying if you have it
on there
all anyone wants to send you is it jobs
right
um yeah when you establish expertise
that's that's the thing
like if you if you become the expert on
a thing then
people are gonna naturally send you that
work because you know
what we're all looking for is someone
who's going to make our problems
disappear so if i have an i.t problem
and you show me that you're an i.t
expert that's what i'm going to give you
that's what you're going to do so if you
don't want that work you kind of have to
keep that off the resume you got to keep
that off the off the radar you know yeah
i would say if you have the ability to
my biggest takeaway would be
let you know if you have a good
relationship with the person who is your
manager
in turn or otherwise let them know like
let them know the problem that you're
facing hey
i feel stagnated right now if they are
not receptive to that
then yeah you definitely want to be
somewhere else anyway right but now
there's no guilt there there's no
nothing
you you've done that right but if you're
underpaid let your manager know right
like
you know if they try to help you out and
work with you awesome if they don't then
yeah it's time
time to look elsewhere so then circle
back to the beginning of setting up a
resume
for the job you want figure out the the
whys of those technologies and now
you're armed to go into interviews and
talk about them
absolutely all right i'm going to ask
you one last one because i think this is
this is going to be a good point to end
on um so
blahya asks how do you learn to code and
program if you don't know enough about
computers uh
it looks like while you didn't grow up
with computers and i know that you also
didn't grow up with computers i spotted
that question in the chat i was going to
ask you if we could get to that in the
end yeah so i never
had a computer in my home uh growing up
uh
and i would say like i'm not normally
one to say like
learn the fundamentals uh you know
before you go but
having a basic understanding of how
computers work
being able to like use like a keyboard
like i forget what they call it like the
the proper you know typing like i used
to two fingers like this and like if
you're in a situation where that's all
you can do then yes of course that's all
you can do
but if you're capable absolutely like
learn how to type uh so that you don't
have to be
looking at the keyboard every two
seconds like once you understand the
basics of computers and you've
internalized that
it opens up the ability to focus on
programming right because you're right
now you're trying to learn
two things at once right and that's
always going to be a problem so let's
break it down into smaller pieces
let's attack the things let's put them
in order and let's attack them one by
one
get comfortable on a keyboard then get
comfortable with how computers in the
internet works
and you don't have to go deep again
again just why how does this work like
the basics of the internet how does that
work
and start from there and then get your
way into programming
it doesn't mean you can't be reading
blog posts about programming and doing
stuff like that and messing around but
invest the time up front
to really get comfortable with computers
because
you're trying to make it your full-time
job right
and again you don't have to know you
don't have to know how to drive a car to
be a mechanic
at all you really don't like you could
be an amazing mechanic and not know how
to drive a car
um but you can't be a mechanic and not
know how to use your tools
right and i think that that is a
difference right like
in this case a keyboard is a tool and
you got to be proficient with it if you
want to be a good developer
one way that i've that i've heard this
described that i really like is
um you know when you are writing code
you you're not just thinking about you
know you're thinking about the problem
that you're trying to solve you're
thinking about the
the code that you're writing you're
thinking about what you're typing into
the keyboard like you said
so when you see somebody who is really
proficient at this
they've moved to what is called
unconscious competence
right where they're no longer thinking
about that and and we're all
unconsciously competent at something
maybe we
can you know sing a song without
thinking about the melody maybe we
are you know we can uh like juggle a
soccer ball
maybe we can you know anything like you
any sports that you can play without
really thinking about where you're
where your body is moving um any
anything like if you can type without
having to think about your fingers and
you can just say you know you're you're
typing like you speak
each one of those things removes a
cognitive load from the work that you're
doing and it lets you just
play and that's where excellence can
really be born if you have to think
about every step in the way
you're just you're gonna have so many
blockers it doesn't mean you can't but
it's gonna
it's gonna slow you down it's gonna slow
you down greatly it's gonna frustrate
you
uh you know it's it's gonna force you to
split your
the the like the cognitive load you have
in your head
amongst multiple things yeah it's like
it's you know i'm not
going to go too deep into it but the
thing i love about types types
allow me to take so much state and throw
it out of my head and rely on something
else
to provide that information for me so i
can focus only on the problem at hand
not remembering
what if this is a freaking string or
number or whatever
right like i don't have to worry about
that i can just move forward
focus solely on the goal yeah so as many
things as you can
turn into what did you call that sub
unconscious unconscious competence
i love that unconscious competence all
the things
folks yeah and this is a it's a it's a
theory that you can read on if i can't
remember who
came up with it but it's uh like an
educational theory when you first
start learning something you go from
unconscious incompetence which is where
you don't know that you don't know
something
then you go to conscious incompetence
which is when you realize that there's a
thing you don't know
and if for somebody who's just starting
programming that's probably where you
feel you know that you could program but
you're not sure how to make it happen
then you study you train you get to
conscious competence
where if you think about it if you focus
you can do the job
and then where mastery comes in is
unconscious competence where you're able
to do the thing without thinking
this is where somebody who can play a
piano by ear or
somebody who you know you like anything
that you can just do
if you can walk and chew gum and you
don't have to think about either of
those things
you are unconsciously competent at
walking and chewing gum right
absolutely um
well kurt so we are we are at the end of
our time so thank you again so much for
sharing your story i know
that uh your time is super valuable and
and i know that
like what a hell of a ride you've been
on so thank you again for for taking the
time to
share with us today yeah thank you for
having me uh
time might be valuable but i can't think
of anything more valuable than
giving this information to the community
i'm available
on uh twitter uh at kurt kemple just my
whole name together if you have more
questions follow up hit me up i'll try
to get to them as soon as i can
i hope you all do amazing things i can't
wait to see what you do and yeah thanks
again for having me
yeah thanks again to free code camp for
hosting this uh if you want to see more
live programming i run a show twice a
week called learn with jason we've got
an episode coming up on tuesday you can
find that at learnwithjason.dev
you can find me on twitter at j
langsdorf jay and my last name
langsdorff
uh kurt thank you again chat thank you
for hanging out quincy thanks for
hanging out in the chat and moderating
we will see you next friday with another
wonderful guest
we'll see ya later everyone